i was worth two million dollars on paper
and i've never been more unhappy in my
life somebody is gonna get started in
crypto and nfts
has a similar mentality i don't
understand this stuff i'm not a money
guy the rich keep getting richer but i
don't know something about this year i i
want to give it a shot
they don't have a lot to invest what are
they doing what's their first step
people make bad decisions because they
need to protect their ego and they get
put in a situation where the only way to
protect their ego is to hide or be
defensive or whatever if you invest like
that then you're good and it doesn't
matter pretend i'm on my deathbed evan
and tom what's your regret
one of my huge regrets would be
mr tom
in the house
how are we doing good man how are you
i'm very well all right listen i gotta
ask you a question do you recognize some
of the characters on this hoodie
oh my god
holy hell did you get that made
okay so this is this this is how amazing
your discord is you have you have an
awesome uh person named maddie i don't
know if you recognize a name or not
she's from estonia and when i first
bought my legendary key she's like send
me the actual key and i want to make
something for you and so
she made this and shipped it from
estonia i'll stand up
this is my that's my key this is it
right here
goes into the pocket these are all like
the little characters that are for my
key
she put like the uh logo here and anyway
i said you know what maddie i'm gonna
wear this when i do my one-on-one with
tom
wow and here we are so dope well maddie
you have all my love that is wicked cool
i love it okay we've got a whole bunch
of nft stuff to talk about but i
promised maddie that i would ask the
first question from her because of this
awesome all right uh so this is from
maddie from estonia passionate
impactivist hi tom i'm a visual and
material artist with a mission to bring
more joy and meaningful reminders of
light into the world i hope to encourage
and inspire others to tune into their
inner light by being a thoughtful
creative giver myself question
if you were a visual or material artist
and you had the same kind of mission as
impact theory what kind of art would you
make to make it tougher filmmaking and
writing is off limits
i think the thing i would really be
focused on is you want something that is
interactive so the more we play in web 3
the more i'm thinking about what could i
for us what can we create that actually
lets people interact with that and
deepen their relationship to the content
some way so if she's got a thesis that
she's trying to put out into the world
in what can you create i'm gonna give
terrible ideas because i am not uh what
what she is but imagine hiding like if
hidden in your sweatshirt there were
symbols that meant something and there
was one that was surprising like we
still haven't minted um there's one
symbol of course that i've alluded to
before the the 51st symbol which i only
think i've said that out loud once
before uh
and it hasn't been minted and so
that like finding that symbol burying
something in the art that lets people
that really want to engage with her
mission to find it and then be the one
to find it now you you're creating
something that people can really engage
with so the art is both beautiful and
complete in and of itself
but if you can put something in it that
allows people to engage and participate
and that i think is the right way to
think about the reason web3 is going to
work is that human psychology is such
that we all want to participate and
something means way more to us when we
can engage deeply with it and that's
really the ethos that i think web3 is
bringing out so
yeah that's what i would do find ways to
make it so that people can really engage
with that piece of art
all right maddie that was for you and
listen you're you're getting recognized
we're wearing it on the stream
and the next time i go see tom and hug
him i'm going to wear this too
okay let's dive in so tom uh you
i'd like to say that the impact theory
keys i think it's the first 100 billion
dollar project
you know i think i think uh we got punks
and apes are like 5 billion each ish so
i don't think you beat them to 10 but
but i think on a long enough timeline
there it is
tom billy who takes it as the first 100
billion project
how does that sit with you
yeah i love it um
i don't i don't think about it in terms
of revenue numbers if i'm completely
honest so but every time you say it i
like the sound of it uh
but i do think that i have the right
thesis
of where this all goes when we get to
the masses and so
i feel like we're building something
that right now makes us look atypical
but i think flash forward five years ten
years i think that we are doing it in
sort of the default way which is to
create emotional connection between the
ip
the nft and the person that owns it um
and right now there's so much focus on
the trade ability on the gambling
aspects that we look anomalous um but i
don't think that plays out in the long
term i think that the the question of
how human psychology plays out has
already
played out so this is just a new
playground for the same thing and so you
know as i say history doesn't repeat but
it rhymes um i think that the way that
the world is now will rhyme with the way
that the world is in web 3 and i think
that emotion and connection and feeling
like yo i now get to own this thing that
i care deeply about versus yo i get to
own this thing and if i watch really
closely and i know what the floor price
is and i time it just right that i can
make money
that speaks very clearly to a large
number of people and they've brought so
much energy to the space so i'm not
denigrating the people that trade in the
slightest i've done some trading myself
but when i think about
i follow the matrix the matrix matters
to me like it i have actually
constructed a part of my identity around
the matrix and so things that let me
attach to that or i came to um harry
potter late like i read harry potter
this or in 2021
and i fell in love with it so hard that
i wanted things that allowed me to
connect more deeply to the brand so
anyway that's what we're doing that's
how we're engaging i think it's so
aligned with human psychology that i
think that we have a very good shot of
becoming a massive
brand
you talk about floor price and uh
that call that you did
where you kind of address the issues
around floor price where it's supposed
to be like a 15-minute call that led to
two and a half hours if you just like
taking every question and and no matter
how kind of rude it was just listening
and you you taking it and saying hey
it's on me even if it's my team it's me
because i'm running this thing and i'm
all for it give me your your feedback
that that's one of my top 10 business
moments of all time dude um
i texted you after like that was a
master class
and because you could see people make
videos you see people on youtube give
advice but you actually lived it you
know like that was a
probably not one of your favorite
moments to to sit through but you know
maybe overhype the project a little bit
and and some of the wrong people came in
and you said hey i'm all for i'll buy
back i'll burn it
you tell me what i'm doing wrong and
i'll fix it and it was very public and i
just
i hope it's one of those moments that i
hope if i'm ever in that situation that
i would have the balls to do that
i feel like i'd be too cowardly to even
be in that situation in the first place
but uh dude that was one of my top ten
so one of those moments is like oh if i
ever get there i hope i can pull off a
tom billy
you will it will be very easy it look
those moments are pretty straightforward
so if you are
i want good things for people and i
really believe that um there are ideas
that i have spent the last 25 years of
my life soaking in that actually work
and all i'm trying to do is present
ideas that work and so the ideas that i
present are the ones that i use every
day they're the ones that you use you
know these ideas and so
living them becomes easy because they
work and so you know that yeah that
stuff i think you know if you have the
right mindset which you do then it
becomes a pretty straightforward it's
not like there was another option i mean
of course you can always do something
else but
um to be the person but dude like what
most people do like most people would
hide would deny
would blame would pass the but like
those are all
legit options that most people take
i mean
yeah it's interesting if you so carol
dweck is careful to differentiate
between a growth mindset and a false
growth mindset and i have learned that
what a what a growth mindset is
optimized for is results and so if you
know that to get the result that you
want you only need to adopt a growth
mindset then suddenly you make some very
careful decisions
largely around what you build your ego
around so people make bad decisions
because they need to protect their ego
and they get put in a situation where
the only way to protect their ego is to
hide or be defensive or whatever
but if you build your self-esteem around
not around being right but around
identifying the right answer around
staring nakedly at your inadequacies and
also i just have a fundamental belief
that the only way to get better is to
iterate and so no matter how mad people
get as i'm iterating it still is the
path forward and so um you can't iterate
well unless you are looking truly at
what is working what the state of things
is and then addressing it from there and
so
yeah i mean that that to me is it's just
effective so
um
really acknowledge the truth of the
situation really acknowledge what you
need to do differently to get a
different result and then go do that
thing and then as long as you do that
enough times you will win which is why i
say on a long enough timeline i can beat
anyone at anything of course i know that
isn't literally true um but if you act
as if it is true you take the right
steps
yeah i guess what's great is that you
see it be put into
motion when
when truth is common like when you're up
against a wall
what do you do and it's like i want
tom bill you on my team i don't know i
just it was one of my favorite moments
um very kind
when did you decide to become
a finance guy or at least to learn and
educate because you've been you've been
the mindset guy and the health guy and
the entrepreneur guy and it's like i'll
just make the money and i'll give it to
my advisors and they'll do whatever with
it just don't lose me money to then
watch your journey of bringing people on
learning about crypto asking all the
dumb questions having us kind of learn
alongside you like when did you flip
that oh i need i actually care now like
you've had enough money to retire and
buy the island and whatever but i
actually care about this now and i need
to
teach other people about this it's
become that important
so the seed got planted when coveted
kicked off and at the beginning of the
pandemic i really was afraid that
people were going to get devastated
financially by it and you know it's hard
to recapture now because the government
is has really come in and pumped a lot
of stimulus in but at the beginning of
the pandemic i didn't know what was
coming and i was just really really
worried
and
so i started interviewing financial
experts and realized that none of them
knew how to talk to the average person
at least not the people that i had
contacts with and could get on the show
and they were all like really high level
macro people
and so i just i was like somebody has to
answer this question and then
i had been getting harangued by one of
my employees
for i don't know eight or nine months
and he was like tom you've got to look
at bitcoin it's almost irresponsible
that you're not looking at this and
please look at it like he had made
insane gains and he was like you just
you have to check it out and i kept
saying david look i
am very good at making money that's what
i have put myself towards for the last
you know 25 years and i have no interest
in getting good at
learning how to invest money and you
know there's a very true quote which is
you can be anything you want to be but
you can't be everything you want to be
and so
i would love to you know go learn more
about this that or the other but i i
only have time to get truly mastery
level at so many things and so
learning finance learning investing
wasn't one of those things i just wasn't
that interested in it and then
uh
about six months into him haranguing me
about learning about bitcoin somebody
says to me hey tom
you need to learn about nfts
and i'd never heard the letters nft
strung together in a sentence before and
i went and looked at it and i was like
wait a second this is i had learned
about digital scarcity about five years
before that moment and i said when i saw
digital scarcity this is going to change
my business forever and i then promptly
forgot about it and that today is what
we call nfts and the technology wasn't
ready when i first learned about it and
unfortunately the the guy that was
running that business that business
ended up folding it was just ahead of
its time
and
um
as i learned about the blockchain which
so 72 hours after hearing nft for the
first time i had allocated millions of
dollars to build uh web3 stuff and
completely pivoted the company to become
a web3 company just was self-evident to
me that this is one of the ways that the
average person was going to be able to
gain financially from the things that
they loved and wanted to support and so
it just was so clear that again to line
up with psychology that this was going
to be the future and that i wanted to
i thought i could help people more by
really going down that path and i
thought that i could disrupt the legacy
players by embracing a new technology
that i knew that they would be slow to
adopt and so um
in all of that you learn about the
blockchain in learning about the
blockchain you inevitably learn about
bitcoin ethereum and learning about
bitcoin and ethereum you start learning
about macro trends and learning about
how money works and as you learn about
how money works you get more and more
angry at sort of the ridiculousness of
the system which then
made me feel like i had a moral
obligation
i already was worried about people from
the pandemic but now i felt like in a
moral obligation like holy hell i'm
learning about something that i've
gotten this far in my life without
knowing about now that i know about it i
really want to tell other people because
i think that they can do something with
the information
and so yeah that that got me obsessed
and then from there i started investing
in my own life
and look crypto's up and down but if
you'd asked me you know even a month ago
dude i'm i'm up an obscene amount
from my crypto and so it's like god here
we are the rich getting richer again
which i don't find inherently
interesting even though i am
theoretically the person that's meant to
be advantaged by that idea
it
what web3 what bitcoin
what the blockchain introduces is now
truly the only thing that separates
the average person from just an
incredible investor other than access to
that starting capital is ideas
now that's a world i'm excited about
that's a world that i'm literally trying
to bring forward is that a set of ideas
changed my life i'm trying to pay those
ideas forward they have nothing to do
with me the ideas existed long before me
they will exist long after me
and
now a new set of ideas exists that can
give people true financial freedom they
have to still be smart and they have to
play the game well you have to learn all
about it you have to understand the
risks and all of that
but
i learned
this would have been
i don't know man maybe eight years ago
i didn't know what an accredited
investor was
and all of a sudden i found myself an
accredited investor and i was like well
i don't understand i still don't know
anything about finance but because i was
worth over a million dollars i was
suddenly an accredited investor so i was
like wait a second now because i have
money i can make more money i was like
why
five years ago
didn't i have the kind of access that i
have now like this is absurd and i
remember saying to somebody why are
people rioting in the streets over this
like this seems insane
you've created a system where just
because i have money you assume i know
more like it was just too weird to me
and because i didn't grow up with money
like this is all very foreign to me
right so i you can take the kid out of
tacoma but you can't take tacoma out of
the kid and so it's like i still have
that sort of teetering on rural
sensibility of like
i'm not smarter than the next person so
now it feels weird that you're giving me
access to things other people don't have
access to so i think that the blockchain
and web3 equalizes that and of course
that was the whole point but i came to
this all backwards right i came to this
from already having generated wealth
learning about nfts first and then
backing into the blockchain so that i
could build on top of it
you've tied your identity to being the
learner
is there anything in looking back
on the whole david situation that
could have been better that instead of
it taking nine months to act it's nine
weeks or nine days or nine hours or you
just needed to unfold as it did
here
to some extent it's just going to unfold
the way that it did but here is the
question i'm always asking myself
there's something i'm ignoring right now
that's going to be the next huge thing
and how do you
get yourself in the context to
actually be prepared to move on that
because now i'm spending so much time in
web 3
that it's like
i only have so much time so if there's
some other fringe thing and people are
trying to get me to pay attention to it
it's like hey i've only got so much time
i can do anything i want but not
everything i want so to some degree you
have to lop off things and not pay
attention to them and you know the
brain's job is really to get good at
knowing what to pay attention to and
what not to pay attention to so i can't
be too mad it's like look we've ended up
having this insane win in the realm of
nfts
it's my future i think it's it is this
incredibly advantageous thing to
humanity so i i can't be too mad that i
didn't make even more money in you know
bitcoin and ethereum and all that had i
found it earlier but i do find it all so
fun to kick myself in the ass a little
bit and be like hey
the guy was in your face like so you do
need that cadre of people that you take
seriously and just go do a bit of
investigation and be careful what story
you tell yourself because i kept
repeating that i don't want to learn
investing and because i kept repeating i
don't want to learn investing i didn't
learn investing until i was literally
forced in order to pursue something else
so yeah be thoughtful you know spend a
little bit of time before you reject
something when it's coming from people
you respect
for all the david's out there what could
he have done better
you know david's real problem is that he
doesn't believe in himself enough so
i'll
hopefully this will be recorded and we
can play this back in 10 years i will
tell you right now david is
so much more intelligent than he
realizes and when he gets confident he
will be unstoppable
if he had my confidence in his
intelligence he would be an unstoppable
machine but he's in his early 20s and he
just doesn't know enough about life
to have that level of conviction and
belief in himself and so he presents it
as like i don't know
maybe
you might want to
whereas i'm like hey
look let's go a moral obligation to tell
you you need to go look at this and so
even though i'm telling people look i
could be wrong i know that but i you
must go look at this for the sake of you
your children like go look at web3 go
investigate nfts go look at blockchain
cryptocurrency it is so important and
his presentation to me was like hey you
might want to consider and it wasn't
until the end where he was like you know
tom like my portfolio is really up but
he's still like you know you got to be
careful and and so
i don't know for me it would have worked
better if he had been like tom you're
the one constantly telling me that i'm
so smart like
this smart guy is telling you you need
to look at this you need to look at it
today if he had presented something like
that it might have cut through the story
that i was telling myself i like it and
for anybody who doesn't know tom or hung
out with him when tom gets something in
his mind it's coming out you're gonna
know he will aggressively get in your
face and tell you what's up which is why
we love tom um let's talk community for
a second so when you first launch your
youtube channel i was so
pumped for your community vibe i know
coming from quest you built it all
through influencers and building
community and celebrating people and
then you come to youtube and you're in
the comments every day and cheering
everybody on and impactivists and like
viewing parties and little chapters in
different cities
and then there was like this era when
you crossed a million subscribers and it
kind of went dark and it's like i don't
know
you could pass a million and the trolls
come out or forget what your comment was
something like that
um
but then you look at what you've built
inside discord and it feels like this is
what you've always been trying to do at
scale finally like you have the best
discord community i'm in there every day
i've done thousands of posts in there
it's it's amazing and so
like some people do it everybody says
it's about the community really but most
people aren't actually hardcore
committed to it
how have you been approaching community
why is it so important what are your
thoughts were you taking it
yeah so this is really interesting so
what i realized is historically i have
always said i'm good at building
communities and what i realized i was
good at building audiences and now with
web3 you actually have community and so
i'll define community as ownership and
participation and so now that people can
actually own the keys own these
collectibles that have this utility that
have you know ongoing value
and as we build out more web three items
they can actually get in there and
participate
um you've got something far more
meaningful and so
now that this is really community it's
getting really really interesting and so
discord while probably not the
the communication platform in its final
form i i think that there's maybe some
pokemon levels to go still uh in terms
of what that ultimate thing is going to
be
but getting people together in a way
that's engaged giving them ways that
they can create within your ecosystem
creating
incentives and a sandbox where people
can play giving them assets that they
can build with that's just a whole
another level and so you know look i
don't get to spend as much time in
youtube comments or on instagram or in
discord as i would like there there are
a few things more intoxicating than
connecting with people honestly my
favorite favorite is in person um
discord has been a close second because
it's far more real time than something
like youtube comments um but at some
point your your the battle that you
fight is
that
you're trying to build something that
takes so much time and i think this a
lot like whenever i'm in social media
and engaging i'm not building something
for the people i'm trying to serve so it
it is a bit of a conundrum so
i want to do more i want to be able to
engage more but i also want to make sure
that i create something that really
matters and improves people's lives and
what we're trying to do with our
our discord our our web 3 initiatives
full stop
is
create incentive structures such that if
you're winning at gamified impact theory
you're winning at real life
and so we're working and look all this
takes time and i'm so
aware now of how people in web 3 have
very short time horizons and so when i
talk about things that i'm building i
know they think i'm launching it this
afternoon um but you know we're reaching
out behind the scenes to try to build
bridges like literal technological
bridges
with health companies and things like
that so that we can pull into our
ecosystem things like your blood glucose
level i can't do it today i don't even
know that i'll be able to do it the next
year i don't know i'll be able to do in
the next two years but this gives you
the idea of the kind of thing that we're
building towards where the things that
we're incentivizing in impact theory so
go take an impact theory university
class do the 90-day challenge like these
are things that will earn you points in
the impact theory ecosystem which will
then translate into impact theory tokens
which you can then spend on things that
matter certainly within the impact
theory ecosystem and hopefully on things
that you can actually then further
monetize yourself we're working hard
behind the scenes to build all those
dynamics but
all of that to say
if your goal is actually so
think of it this way i'm i'm 18 years
old i meet this eight-year-old kid he is
being consumed alive by his zip code i
don't realize that's what's happening at
the time but now i see uh end up working
with him it's the wrong word i end up
treating him like my little brother for
eight and a half years and caring about
him and thinking about him and loving
him and wanting good things for him
and
you know life does what life does he
ends up getting moved really far away i
end up moving to london we end up losing
contact
and you know lo and behold he does get
eaten by a zip code and things have not
yet uh turned out ideally
for what i would want for him is
somebody that i love and care about
um and flash forward 15 years later i've
got a thousand employees that remind me
of him and i started thinking about okay
how do you really pull this off
and
part of the reason i'm so passionate
about the discord and community over an
audience
is that now we can create these things
together that hopefully actually give
them actionable ways to improve their
lives because as you've heard me say a
bazillion times i'm i'm really like
actually afraid so pretend i'm on my
deathbed evan
and tom what's your regret
one of my huge regrets would be that i
just end up being spiritual
entertainment
and people use me
as
ultimately they're using my presentation
style and the ideas to feel better for a
minute
but they could actually use
those ideas to change their life forever
and that's far more interesting to me
and so
that's what
this version of community is allowing me
to do i hope that's certainly what we're
striving for is that we can create
something that allows them to take
action why do you care so much so i mean
you
in knowing you you're not like the most
extroverted guy
life of the party like ah saying hi
that's that's lisa you know lisa's like
true the best
so but it on the surface it looked weird
like this guy who kind of not just keeps
himself but has his you know just doing
his thing cares so much about community
why does tom bill you it's not just a
strategy for you like oh this is gonna
serve and it's gonna help my project
like you actually deeply care
why
so nature uh has two sticks or two
levers pleasure and pain
and i learned very early on in my
entrepreneurial career that
money did not necessarily accompany
nature's pleasure
lever and so i was worth two million
dollars on paper and i'd never been more
unhappy in my life
and i remember my wife pulled me aside
and she's like
look you're now damaging the marriage
this isn't fun anymore you're not having
fun i'm not having fun you're getting
difficult to be around because you're so
unhappy and so i realized through that
experience that
i had been chasing money like like
stating it every day i'm chasing money
that like i said it like i'm chasing
money you know as if i was revealing
something amazing about myself
and i'm here to get rich and
i realized that i was making more money
than i'd ever made in my life i was
worth more money on paper but i was
worth more money than i'd ever been in
my whole life and i felt emotionally
bankrupt
so i was like well i'm never doing this
again i went in and quit and i said i
will never chase money ever again in my
life now the flip side of that coin is
the realization that only meaning and
purpose matter and that's nature so
nature's like hey i need you to survive
long enough to have kids that have kids
and i only have pleasure and pain to get
you there so i'm going to make sex
incredibly pleasurable and trick you
into having children
i'm going to make having a child
insanely purposeful
and so that you'd be willing to die for
this child and that sense of like i
would protect this child with my life is
an amazing feeling
and so i realized through all of this
that i'm a social creature i have a
brain
built over millions of years of
evolution to make sure
that i serve the group in some way
because that's gonna guarantee my
survival or come closer to it and so
when you know there's only pleasure and
pain so serving the group pleasure gets
yanked on you feel awesome
and if you don't
pain gets yanked on so even just i knew
if i go retire to an island which my
life would be way more stress-free
because trying to help
is not stress-free evan let me tell you
right
it's like there is a lot of stress and
you know look i'm building all of this
with my own capital so it's like to fail
is to lose a lot of money and that's why
it makes me laugh whenever somebody's
like oh tom's in this for the cash grab
do you know how much my own personal
money i have put in and never taken out
i've not taken a dime out of impact
theory in five plus years
and
because i know that had i bought the
island and retire it would be fun
for a while not gonna lie and i don't
know if that would have been fun for a
month three months a year maybe even
three years
but eventually it becomes
not fun because nature starts going
you're not contributing to the group
and it's just this evolutionary pressure
that we all have and we think at least i
did when i was young i thought that as
long as i didn't detract from the group
i would be fine but it actually doesn't
work like that and so you be you begin
to feel this deep sense of dis ease
right so
hence the word disease like
you just don't feel right something's
wrong i don't know what it is i just
don't feel good and then it slides into
depression and then people don't know
why they're depressed
and
one of and of course it's myriad reasons
because another one of the reasons is
you're not contributing almost certainly
another is your diet i mean there's a
whole host of reasons how people end up
there but when i realized that whoa
fighting really hard for somebody that i
love and care about and i want to see
win
that makes you feel something that's
it's not replicated anywhere else and so
money's awesome it's actually more
powerful than people think but it's not
at all what they've been told money
cannot change how you feel about
yourself i could give you a billion
dollars and if you have low self-esteem
you will still have low self-esteem
you'll just have a lot of money and low
self-esteem and so i got to learn that
up close thankfully before i actually
generated wealth and so
it was all the realizations around why i
wasn't happy that money wasn't helping
me that made me go well then i'll never
live for money again now of course irony
of ironies i make that decision right as
social media is coming into play and so
in building a business predicated
entirely on adding value to people's
lives and meaning to my own life
that i built a billion dollar brand
but through all of that i realized the
only thing that matters is how i feel
about myself when i'm by myself when
there's no one there to cheer me on
there's no one there to tell me i'm cool
um and i need to be protected from any
negative things that i've heard about
myself or whatever the only thing that's
there is like have i done things
to
translate my potential into actual
usable skill set and then use that skill
set to help people because if you do
that you have fulfillment if you have
fulfillment you have protection
and so yeah i just knew i have to
optimize my life for fulfillment and so
i
when i left quest
monday was my last day and tuesday was
my first day at impact theory i didn't
take a single day off
i love it dude walt disney you like to
say you know he's your role model you
want to build the next walt disney
uh one of my favorite things to do you
know inside the it discord is hey when
they unfreeze walt disney he's going to
look at tom billy and say i want to be
the next tom bilyeu
if you were to look at disney though
imagine disney's coming back
but as a youngin you know he's on his
come up and he's he's born into this era
and he's 18 19 20 or however old he was
and who was doing kind of ambulance
driver
uh caricatures in the war
what do you think disney's doing in this
era
oh he he was a storyteller to his course
so
where do i think he would go he'd
probably go into gaming you know gaming
is such the
the place right now and as somebody who
was trying to build real cities like he
was he was an immersive world builder
before world building had a name
um so yeah i would i would think he
would probably start out the same way
that he did uh an indie game developer
that not that he started out as an indie
game developer but he started out making
indie
animated films uh at a time by the way
when people were like dude animation's
played out it's done it's dead as disco
um how ironic and
yeah just create these immersive
experiences that people are really moved
by um he seemed to have a real insight
into
human psychology and
what made them laugh or smile and so i
imagine he would create these rich
environments and i don't i don't know
how many people understand
just how much
games have won the entertainment battle
between
film tv and gaming it's not by a little
it's by a lot
are we gonna get you to play some league
of legends
oh i actually tried league of legends uh
you definitely will get me to watch
arcane i've watched the first three
episodes have you seen it there we go i
can't get my wife into it i'm a hardcore
league of legends player but uh we can't
get my wife you're you're a fan eh
brother it's so good it's so good where
now i'm like whoo riot making me sweat
like damn uh so yeah riot i think right
now in terms of a media company that is
stepping outside of their core
competency into storytelling there's
nobody doing it better like it was
unbelievable um so
because your wife isn't into it have you
not seen it
we saw the first episode but that's it
you keep going it's
phenomenal i'm gonna tell her tom bill
you said you have to keep watching you
must absolutely do that
and uh it is
it is a creative team at the height of
their powers
it's a sight to behold
is part of what you want to do
to
find and train and partner with the next
walt disney's
you know god dude evan get like are you
spying on me so we just had a
conversation last night so i was talking
to the writing team
which is one of the great joys of my
life
and
we're using a system that is it's making
things way harder for us so
much like disney we have there's only a
finite number of stories that we're
willing to tell i shouldn't say number
of stories there's only a finite number
of themes that we're willing to tell
because i won't tell a story that isn't
empowering in its nature now i'll give
you examples of movies that i wish we
had made star wars
um karate kid the matrix
um my hero academia naruto like there's
plenty of amazing things that are wildly
entertaining but also have this core of
empowerment but we only want to tell
empowering stories and so the problem is
that
to tell an empowering story you must
actually understand the ideas of
empowerment which is not easy especially
not for a beginning writer and so if
you're in your sort of early to mid 20s
which is like that sweet spot for a
writer who's just beginning they're on
the come up
they
to ask them to write a story about
empowerment is hard because if they
could do it they'd be living it
and most of them of course just like i
wasn't in their you know early to mid
20s that's just not they haven't learned
those lessons yet and so
we're trying to find that system and one
of the ideas put forth was we may have
to offer a school
where you learn to write in the impact
theory way and i was like i'm down for
it and that was certainly something that
walt disney did he realized that he
wanted to
teach people to animate to write in the
disney way and so he's like well i have
to create my own university and so yeah
i mean i think that's an inevitability
but bridging the gap between where we
are and that because that takes years um
is is a tricky beast that we are
processing through right now
i mean i remember watching one of the
documentaries on disney and yeah setting
up that school also just to make
feature-length cartoons because it
didn't exist
you know like there were only these
little tiny shorts and he went and made
a full-length feature movie snow white
and people thought he was crazy he
actually had to go
dance on this guy's table as ip giannini
started bank of america gave walt disney
the money to fund
snow white when everybody thought he was
crazy um
he was a little crazy man have you heard
the story about
he had they were trying to do this
incredible groundbreaking shot that
required like an entire airplane hangar
because they had to to film through
these different plates of glass so they
could get the depth and things would
move at different rates
unbelievable
and it was so time consuming and they
were so up against the deadline that he
had to convince one of the people
working on the shot to get married in
the airplane hangar so that there would
be no downtime imagine trying to
convince your wife we were about to go
get married in this beautiful church or
whatever and now
to get walt's going to pay for it but
now we have to get married in the
airplane hangar so i can save my vows
and get back to work how bananas is that
that's the cl what's the closest thing
that's happened for you because your
team is pretty epic and hardcore and i
mean what i remember when i came to your
place um i thought it was just coming
your house i mean which was your house
but also like this compound
it's like 30 cars outside everybody's
working from different tables you've got
a pretty hardcore team what's what's
like let's give a shout out to somebody
on the team for insane dedication to the
cause man that that's almost too
difficult to narrow down so i'll give a
few so
getting the
the nfts across the finish line that
that was actually more difficult more
time consuming than launching a new
protein bar flavor
which i i would not have believed until
i did it uh but yeah the team that was
involved in getting both the keys and
the
merry mods across the finish line
wow so that was hoss
connor david will
um paul
uh
god we had so many people
i'm forgetting so many i want to punch
myself in the mouth
um the all the artists that worked on it
it was it was an unimaginable team
effort of a lot of people
pulling a lot of weight to get this
thing uh across the finish line but it
was so incredible and i'm so proud and i
was so dazzled uh by the team and their
work ethic and all that yeah it was
pretty incredible one of the more
memorable moments that had you been
there
uh that's probably the moment you're
looking for was
friday 2 a.m back at quest and we're
we've been making protein bars all day
and it that is a grueling job at that
part you would have to trade positions
because you'd start sweating like it was
that kind of thing and you obviously
can't sweat and drip on the the material
but that's how difficult this stuff was
and to ask a bunch of
early 20
gangsters like literal gang bangers to
stay with you at 2 a.m when they thought
they were going to be home at you know 7
00 p.m
and be with their friends and their
girlfriends on a friday night and to get
them to stay and be like
we're on a mission guys we're gonna do
this no matter what it takes i will get
this done stay with me stay focused that
was one of those where like had cameras
been rolling it was a pretty epic moment
to get these guys to come together as a
team we had bloods and crips working the
same line which i actually didn't know
when i hired them but that's a whole
another story but getting all of those
guys for the first time in their life to
work towards a cause to have a mission
something they could believe and focus
them on skill acquisition on getting
better it was unreal i i will forever
be grateful for that period of my life
where because this is before i've made
money so this is early man this is tom
driving a ford focus it's beat up leaky
exhaust like bumming rides off my own
employees you know dealing with building
this thing in compton and having to like
get the respect of the different
factions that control the area so that
nobody will with your stuff it was it
was really a crazy amazing time of
earning the respect of some of the
hardest core like
hardcore like do you know what a
teardrop tattoo is like that kind of
hardcore um people working the line
and it was unbelievable and one of them
came up to me
in tears and
you know grown man
tough this kid was put on i don't think
it actually ended up going to trial but
it was on its way to trial um
and he certainly spent time in jail
awaiting trial
for um attempted murder which he did not
do he knew who did it and he refused to
rat because in his neighborhood if you
rap then your family gets killed and so
he wouldn't do it
that guy that kind of hardcore comes in
and he starts crying he's like look man
you care more about my my future than my
own mother
and
i was like
damn like when you give somebody hope
that's never had hope before like that's
a real thing
and that really got me
excited i mean that's part of what
carries me through now is
realizing that
a set of ideas
sets people free
and makes it possible for them to do and
create things that they otherwise
wouldn't have been able to do and create
and that some people have just never
been told that they can do it before
and when you give them that hope it is
life changing
that's where my head was going because
when you said they bought into the
missions like really was that it like
these guys care about ending metabolic
disease it felt a lot more like i think
that was the quest mission it felt more
like you might have been the first guy
to actually just believe in them and
they didn't want to let you down on what
you're doing more so that loyalty then
we're going to build
a billion dollar business that ends
metabolic disease yeah no doubt and the
mission that i had for them because i
didn't often talk about metabolic
disease to them the mission for them was
what we would now call impact theory it
was
look guys
there's a set of ideas that you can use
to acquire skills and what i want to do
is make sure that you work it in that at
quest was an impact area that you work
at quest because you want to not because
you have to and so what i want to do is
arm you with enough skills to be so
valuable that you could leave at any
time to get another job but that you
stay here because we're helping you
acquire those skills and we're investing
in your future
and dude that that's insane what that
does the way that galvanize is a team
the way that gets people excited the way
that you
get just
you get people there at two am on a
friday night it's it's really
unbelievable
how was that process of moving from
you're doing quest
you launch a youtube show
inside quest it's kind of like tom's
doing this rogue thing like i thought we
were building protein bars what's he
doing interviewing tony robbins and
whatever on this
on this show but then you realize hey
now i'm going to go and do my own thing
and you guys run quest obviously still
part of it but not day to day
how was that process to move on
to start impact here you know this is a
question that it would be more fun to
ask with my wife and i together because
we had just very different experiences
my identity is not tied up in what i do
in the slightest my identity is that of
the learner so as long as i get to keep
learning which is why the only thing i
fear is brain damage and losing my wife
so as long as i get to learn like
there was no sense of quest is me so
leaving quest was just like well that's
the point in this journey that i'm at
it's time for me to start this new thing
and
for at least i think it was a lot harder
i think it was she she had to mourn
that right that she was no longer at
quest now she had this new thing to
build and to focus on but
it it was there was a sense of loss for
her that there wasn't for me
and
i feel the same about impact theory i
love impact theory i never intend to
sell impact theory um but if something
were to
happen to me and you know let's say that
i can no longer work on it for some
reason whatever i can't even guess what
that would be but let's pretend
and
my identity wouldn't be damaged by that
and so i just i need meaning and purpose
and i need to be learning
and that's why we've structured impact
theory the way that we have so anyway
for me it was just a very simple
transition it was
knowing the mechanisms because you have
to reorient yourself to a new mission
because without that you're not going to
have the emotional response to meaning
and purpose and since i knew that was
the only thing that mattered i had to go
through this process of really assigning
meaning and purpose
to
impact theory and that that takes you
know call it three to six months before
it's you get a neurochemical reaction
when you think about the meaning and
purpose before that it feels a little
fake like you're trying to attach this
idea it has to be to something real but
there is a whole process that you do to
reinforce that belief uh to the point
where it becomes neurochemical so i had
to go through that but other than that
it was very very easy for me
i wanted to talk about lisa so that's a
great little transition point um when i
was doing my
live stream inside of your discord a
couple weeks back which you were heroic
you're a legend in my mind in the
discord's mind honestly evan
i you're so
um humble
but i want to know to the core of your
being you know what what a generous act
that was
to share that knowledge and you are
freakishly knowledgeable i turn to you
and sit at your feet for insights on a
lot of things and that you share those
insights so freely with anybody who will
listen for over six hours just just
obscenely generous obscenely generous
it's one of the kindest things anybody
has ever done for me certainly for the
community and it's just just an act of
generosity that i am
so grateful for
well thank you man i'm i'm working on
accepting confluence so i appreciate it
thank you
um
that was fun i mean
i've done q and a's before that were
that long but the challenge they didn't
realize was i have to talk the whole
time like i have to read the question
and answer the question there's no break
right so i had i think you were there
for like the first hour and then the
next five like oh i got to do this whole
thing i i had a bottle like i i legit
worried if i have to pee i'm going in
this bottle and i'm going to keep
raising questions
it didn't get to that it didn't get to
that it didn't get to that um anyway but
now i mean the time flew your community
is amazing that that did not feel like
six hours at all um
anyway so we're doing this we're doing
this stream somebody asked me hey evan
you say impact your keys can be the
first 100 billion dollar project
what are the risk factors that you see
happening like how does it not get there
i said there's only one risk factor
that's tom dying because as long as tom
is alive you guys don't know him like he
as long as he is breathing he's gonna
claw he's gonna climb he's gonna run and
fly and crawl to like move this thing
across the finish line
um which was my default answer and then
i stopped myself and said but you know
what there's one more and that's lisa
i think lisa is is the single greatest
underrated asset talent human inside
impact theory and i know she has a lot
of stuff behind the scenes that people
don't often see but but lisa is the real
goat and
uh
i would love to see her get more credit
i know it's never been about like who's
the face and you never even wanted to be
the face
could you and this isn't meant to be
some softball like oh let me say good
things about my wife like
i i i'd like it's part of my mission for
people to recognize how much of a badass
lisa is
and and and she does it with like class
and grace and style in a way it's like
how is this possible
is there
so all of those great things you know
talked about her i would love like a
specific story a recent one not like oh
she was there for me at the beginning
and we did all this stuff and supported
me and all this stuff but like something
recent
that just shows the incredible insane
value
that lisa brings to impact theory in all
these projects
so
yeah i mean one i'll give you an
overarching thing so anybody in my
community has probably heard me say this
before but i'm not a big crier but um
there was one day that i i broke like
down into absolute ugly tears and this
was before lisa became an entrepreneur
and so she's you know housewifing it and
i was just like you're never going to
get enough credit for
who i have become and that i don't even
know who i would be
had i not met you
and the way that she shaped me by
encouragement by rewards and punishments
by letting me know and i've gone astray
by giving me you know god only knows how
many jerry maguire moments where it's
like hey you've got this i believe in
you like you've got to stay focused and
just keep going
and
she really is incredible and now she
stepped into an entrepreneurship role
stepped in front of the camera so people
can see for themselves like how really
extraordinary she is but
behind the scenes like she's she is very
different
um in the way that she moves as an
entrepreneur than i think people would
expect because she is
so sweet and so kind that i don't think
people understand how intense she is
and how smart she is
and she is like and it's really
interesting my wife is an ugly duckling
and for anybody that knows that story
the story of the ugly duckling is a swan
being raised by ducks and if you're a
swan as you know a duckling you look
goofy you look awkward your hunk sounds
funny and so you're getting made fun of
but then one day you turn into a
swan and you look unbelievable but the
rad thing about humans that grow up as
the ugly duckling
is that when they become the swan
they're so
humble because hiding in their heart is
just enough
remembrance of the insecurities
and what it felt like to feel so out of
step and so my wife grew up in a family
that had a different kind of
intelligence because they all are very
bright
but in a different way than she is and
so i think it made her feel like an
outcast it made her feel not intelligent
and
so i meet her and i'm like damn like
this chick is not only very attractive
but she is
very smart but she's so kind and doesn't
seem to understand just how smart she is
and so
watching her move as an entrepreneur and
when something gets off she's really
good with numbers
so she'll be like yo
this should be this if we change this
and do that like we can get it here and
so when i look at
what she's done with her own channels
and how she's gone from
you know zero sub zero followers to just
absolutely becoming this incredible
not only contributor to people
emotionally with ideas and helping to
get the ideas out there
but as a marketer is understanding
youtube instagram tick tock like what to
do how to make things pop off and she
does it like data driven
like understanding what we call the
physics of progress running the physics
of progress more adeptly than virtually
anyone in the company and just she can
step into the like the you know her that
bubbly part of her personality that's
all real that's exactly what she's like
off camera but
another very real part of her is like
wait wait i don't understand that why is
that but this we we talked about this
number we said it was going to do this
and didn't we run that and remember when
evan told us this literally
and
to see her go into that mode i always
just want to stand up and clap and
you know i've told her in no uncertain
terms publicly and privately i've had
extraordinary business partners in my
life
but she's the best
like just from the ability to
supportive to uplift the team to elevate
them to give them clarity of vision to
support them but also to hold them
accountable to results to set the bar by
playing at that level herself and
inspiring people through action
it's really really incredible and it's
very hard to do and it's i also vote her
most likely to get me sued and i
actually mean that i'm not kidding uh my
wife is so loving and just cannot wrap
her head around 2022 and what it means
that you can't just hug people all the
time and so uh she's very loving and
very greek and if you
meet her socially she's gonna make sure
that you're taken care of and she's
gonna throw her arms around you
unfortunately whether you want it or not
and uh yeah it's
she i mean look i've dedicated my life
to her
um
for a reason and i don't say nice things
about her because she's my wife she's my
wife because i believe nice things about
her so yeah i just think she's
extraordinary
shout out to lisa bill you and go give
or follow instagram twitter women of
impact on youtube uh last question tom
somebody is gonna get started in crypto
and nfts
has a similar mentality i don't
understand this stuff i'm not a money
guy the rich keep getting rich here but
i don't know something about this year i
want to give it a shot
they don't have a lot to invest what are
they doing what's their first step
professional education so you need to
come into this saying okay look uh a lot
of smart people are saying that i need
to look at this but i have to form my
own active hypothesis
because especially when you're talking
about money there's a lot of risk so one
learn two engage so get in discords
engage on twitter start forming that
active hypothesis
spend some money that you can afford to
go to zero
and
only invest in things that you are
actually excited to hold if it goes to
zero the number like i'll give you an
example i'm sure that i'm being
pilloried as we speak for a purchase
that i made i spent like i don't know it
had to be
14 grand or something like that was a
lot of money on a project that blew up
it was so big oh my god and then it
tanked and i bought it after a tank
and it's a project that i really think
is
absolutely unbelievable the art is um
just incredible it's some of the best
art in the anime mecca landscape
and
i didn't buy it because i think that
it's going to go to the moon i bought it
because if it goes to zero i'll still be
stoked to have it in my wallet
and so i highly encourage people to
invest in that and i see people asking
for the name the name of it is
mechaverse
um and
dude i love the art i think it's
unbelievable i think it is some of the
best art i've ever seen bar none not
best nfp art best art like you want to
talk about i just think is dope it is
nomadic i will love that until the day i
die that project could implode the
artist could come out and just be a
total jackass whatever his art is
[ __ ] amazing and so yeah i love it
and if you invest like that
then you're good and it doesn't matter
i
do not
look at nfts as
a primary trading vehicle i don't look
at it as a place to store my wealth i do
look at bitcoin and ethereum that way so
full disclosure but again it could be
wrong so do your own research
um
but nfts to me are about emotional
connection so
that's what i encourage people to do in
the research process as you begin to
engage first of all only spend money
that you can afford to lose and then
only spend that money that you can
afford to lose on things that you would
enjoy having even if they go to zero if
you do that you can't lose
what's the one video they should start
with oh go to um and this seems
self-serving but it is not intentionally
go to founders key dot io scroll to the
bottom of the page uh the video that i
created there is for beginners check
that out i think that's the right place
to start and then
we've created if you go to our discord
we have an official links place
uh that you can it's like our beginning
primer course you can go i think that's
a great place to start
and then go to youtube type in the basic
terms watch a bunch of different people
so you're not just getting my point of
view watch a bunch of different people
start seeing who resonates with you and
then just remember and man this this may
become so on the mindset side of things
i'm evangelical about one thing that is
getting people to understand you're
having a biological experience once you
understand that you learn to understand
your biology everything gets a lot
easier
i'm begging you for everybody that's
thinking about embarking on web3 or even
investing in cryptocurrencies as a
currency as
an inflation hedge or just a store of
value
please please please operate in long
time lines
if you go in for the quick stuff you're
going to get wrecked there was a stat
that came out i need to go re-look this
up so i can memorize it but it's
something like
it's certainly less than ten percent it
might be less than five percent so
somewhere between ten and five percent
of all the money being made by traders
on opencr or by metamask wallet i forget
which of the two uh those are the people
making the money that means over 90
are getting ruined they're losing money
and so just like if you're playing the
stock market you're trying to be an
active trader the odds of you making
money are very very low
and so
to treat these
differently i think would be wise so
look at long time horizons
invest in people that you think invest
in people first of all and invest in
people that you think will be in this
for the long run
because
anybody can be up for a minute anybody
can be down for a while but if you
execute over time and establish an
emotional connection then you can win
and so
i'm not interested in buying something
that's up momentarily if it's going to
be down forever and look there's so many
projects that come out of the gate
strong they spend a couple months hot
and then people just get bored and if
they're if they don't know how to run a
business and they don't know how to
build emotional attachment over time
then they're never going to win and it's
it's hard man it's hard and so
getting people in web 3 to embrace web3
but also embrace that you actually want
people to build and so
by getting involved in fewer projects
and engaging over the long run you can
be a meaningful contributor to the
community which actually will have
influence then in how and what gets
built
but also
gives the builders the the emotional
backing that they need from the
community to build the thing you
actually want and so seeing more people
get involved in the space in that way
i'm very passionate about being a voice
talking about that because not a lot of
people are talking about it
education i would say watch tom with
raul paul that was the first interview
you asked so many great questions that
was the first one that everything
started to click for me after that
interview did with him it was i don't
know whatever just the piece is aligned
yeah he's amazing that but you asked
like
like i wish time asked that and it's
like the next thing out of your mouth is
that question yes tom let's go
um michael saylor that was insane most
people watch videos at like 2x speed i
had to slow that one down to like half
speed and listen to the game
fried my brain but it makes a lot more
sense now and then the impact theory
discord man those people are amazing
humans answered all of my stupid
questions like noob getting into it that
i didn't want to bother tom with a text
every four minutes with what does this
mean i will take your
dumbest question any day at carmichael
you have my love my admiration
brother trust me i'm here for you but
yes and shout out to pac-man too man
that guy just did so much heavy lifting
there is somebody that absolutely
deserves a shout out that guy is an
animal
an animal
absolutely breathtaking
i love it we'll link those up down below
tom anywhere else do you want to send
people on youtube too
um i mean you can find me at tombillyou
on youtube if you're interested in web3
follow me on twitter that's where i talk
web3 all day every day um and then yeah
the discord and
look i know i date myself with this
reference but to all the discord people
out there that are here watching i love
you guys so much be excellent to each
other please welcome the new people with
open arms love them try to elevate them
you know i want our discord to be about
winning in life and not just winning in
nfts and so extending that to people
that come in that would mean the
absolute world to me and then i will go
off and make sure that i'm building with
every fiber of my being uh the web 3
stuff and making sure that you guys are
proud long term to be key holders um but
yeah show that love elevate people help
them find that meaning and purpose uh
that's huge for me and our community is
has been just really extraordinary with
that shout out to the melon heads uh
dropping melons there uh if you know you
know as they say um yeah it's incredible
awesome mr tom bill you in the house
thank you man all the love the wisdom
the energy incredible thank you for
joining us and all these questions and
super pumped for everything you're doing
thanks for having me absolute joy
much love take care everybody
later bye if you want to see my last
one-on-one one tom bill you check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there what are you doing
you're not answering the question i'm
asking i felt so hopeless and so lost
and just unsure of how it's going to
make anything in my life the things you
think are rad are the things that will
blow up